[Música]
[Aplausos]
é um é bom dia a todos
eu chamo mike luiz neto formou em física
nuclear e hoje em dia trabalha para
bolsas de valores e normalmente quando
conheço alguém pela primeira vez a
pergunta é quase sempre o que é que faz
um físico nuclear na bolsa
sep eu acredito que todos conhecem cá
albert einstein
provavelmente a pessoa mais fantástica
meta mais brilhante que nós tivemos é
que a física conhecida nos últimos anos
mas a verdade é que ela também foi uma
fonte de inspiração pra mim e disse
estudar física tudo bem
a física contém muita complexidade mas
eu achei certo olhar essa complexidade e
utilizar a nosso favor e uma das coisas
que eu nunca percebi eram fórmulas a
fórmula para calcular a elasticidade do
material é uma das fórmulas mais
complexas é sp gira poder temos aqueles
a que segue se o dia estava a tratar da
mudança a casa de um colega e nós
precisávamos beber uma cerveja refrescar
mas não temos nenhum objeto abrir as
garrafas e foi aí que eu percebi o que
na verdade a fórmula quer dizer é quando
tem o objeto e tudo obras do na verdade
estava duplicar o espaço à área externa
mas ao mesmo tempo está comprimido
a área interna ou seja aqui é um
exponencial
se não fizermos isso à medida que vai
dobrando o material
o material vai ficar duro e este fator é
quatro vezes
portanto cada vez que todo o brasil o
papel ela vai se tornar quatro vezes
mais duro e o que aconteceu depois de um
tempo é que nós percebemos que na
verdade
podíamos beber uma cerveja abrindo com o
papel as coisas bonitas da física né
mas voltando voltando aquilo que press
isso isso e isso foi sua parte sexy da
física
[Aplausos]
há cerca de seis anos atrás eu pensei
voltar a angola uma formação complexa
uma formação com pouca aplicação ea bola
e teve alguma dificuldade não é fácil
encontrar emprego enquanto físico mas
acabei por abraçar outros desafios mas
eu muito rapidamente percebi que o meu
conhecimento por exemplo programação
prometeu fazer vigilância do mercado
o meu conhecimento em modelos
matemáticos permitiram perceber aquilo
que os os financeiros dizem que a gestão
complexa do portfólio de financiamento
portanto rapidamente
eu percebi que a pergunta conseguia ser
respondida
eu passei a ser um canivete suíço o
canivete suíço é fantástico porque
contém várias ferramentas porque não
acho que conseguem fazer uma ou poucas
coisas mas se unir todas essas
ferramentas do tens aí uma ferramenta
com muita força muita utilidade
universal isto não parou por aqui
se me perguntarem também aqui hoje a
vale o caso tudo bem não quando ficarmos
vamos ver que a nossa américa o ministro
og de oito são pessoas que fazem uso dos
seus canivete suíço para resolverem o
máximo possível de problemas
eu sou de opinião ea minha mensagem que
eu gostaria de trazer aqui é que nós
devemos tornar os nossos jovens mais
canivete suíço áfrica tem neste momento
46 por cento dos jovens africanos
dessa forma acabam por não fazer nada no
ramo esfumaram e se pegarmos ainda a
áfrica subsaariana
na nossa zona sadek cerca de 30% desses
46 por cento acaba por nunca sequer
tocar nenhuma matéria ligada à sua área
de formação ou seja há uma grande
necessidade de nos estarmos outras
ferramentas aos nossos jovens para além
daquelas que o curso acadêmico permita
oferecer e hoje em dia com os desafios
como a complexidade como roubar dinâmica
do conhecimento como a automação
tudo isso traz apenas mais e mais e mais
complexidade e para isso nós precisamos
encontrar mais e mais e mais resultados
quando olhamos pra a tendência global
nós vamos ver que até grandes
universidades estão a tentar seguir essa
regra é essa tendência
uma universidade da cingapura passou em
sua 24ª posição no ranking mundial da
biodiversidade para a 23ª isso em menos
de dez anos ou seja o que eu quero dizer
é que em menos de dez anos
esta universidade por ou 30 lugares nos
chamar o responsável esta universidade
perguntaram mas a guerra o que foi que
vocês fizeram né popular sem 30 lugares
a resposta do senhor foi muito simples
fechamos a faculdade de direito
não é mentira é verdade e sempre moral
juristas
tenho amigos juristas e nós sabemos que
tudo o que eu disser aqui pode ser usado
contra mim
infelizmente é o que seis anos atrás se
eu tivesse ingressado no princípio deste
ano se calhar ainda teria tempo para
trabalhar no arroz a ti
quem sabe estar em órbita mas a mensagem
que quero passar é justamente essa
nós precisamos pôr canivete suíço nós
precisamos de pessoas com mais
conhecimento em variadas áreas porque
isso só nos vai prometer ter diversidade
e todos nós sabemos que inovação nas ali
onde a diversidade de saber muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]